however my okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I
yelled but this is the fifth time I'm
recording this hahaha
so I'm gonna mysteriously know exactly
what I need to do or I feel my body
being pulled in this direction ah my
chest as you well know in about an hour
ago um we solve this puzzle or the
puzzle back there for the machinery I
feel my nipples are being pulled this
direction oh wait slowed we over here
and we're like oh well
we solved this in we go over go wander
the hall no wait I did that already
ha ha ow my ankles if you notice this
was here or this was here oh come on
don't be a dare we go [ __ ] hell the
Sun up but I'm sorry I'm angry I'm a
little bit I'm a little bit on edge
because between recording failures and
this being a general douche how about
this is no nevermind
[Music]
it took me like never I'm not even gonna
talk about ok so here we are now we've
reached the limit of my knowledge so let
us explore this water area hello don't
stray from the torches beware of the
darkness and a key
hello this reminds me of cry of fear
hello is there something in the darkness
sit away all right then I'll please know
that you I hear him hurry the car I'm
okay
you like that scream I've been working
on that one for a while
got a lot of the throat activated enough
hello okay all right yay we got a
mechanical door key oh yeah
finally I hope I hope this is recording
correctly oh yeah oh if it's not if it's
not I will oh I will be so angry
oh I will be so angry oh here we pop out
here well you guys don't know about this
place so oh look how bright and
beautiful it is I'm seeing for the first
time oh that sound is new it sounded
horrifying all right so we got a
mechanical door key just through the
trap door which was almost impossible to
find yours and out the door that you
guys are definitely seeing for the first
time along with me as well what is that
sound you guys are hearing that too
right right
da fully peculiar but then again I'm a
weirdo okay so this please go to this
one and then Kurt Schanke Josh let's go
meet this demon in the hall I bet he's
not so bad I bet he's just misunderstood
hello
it's now time to the child
yeah let's not do that let's go in here
first I sent energy radiating from
behind this door well well well well
well well well well well well well well
well well well haha
you probably don't dear Lord said I woke
alongside father feel down I don't
actually have a job at Apple of a little
fuel to turn out early they need a
little more work quite frankly annoying
my approach is being pessimistic lemon
certainly cut understand and so to the
point I was wondering man that noise is
getting louder it is similar to the
stuff that is already prayed played
there and in my opinion probably better
please let me know what you think copy
in the storage rooms all day tomorrow
since I worked part-time as a store man
but I'll be free the following day in
case you wanted to see me in person
Lachlan Lala Lachlan's relic combine
them combination does not work it's over
here his door is locked
yeah right well apparently really is
locked ok that's cool I want to get away
from this noise yeah sometimes my grasp
upon this reality weakens and I find
myself slipping into another world ah
thank God
leave gee willikers that's a lot of
chairs a past me would have been more
excited about this but I have since
become pessimistic towards chairs ok so
we're in a chapel house smart I just
jabbed my hand on random needles
oops okay yeah we did that that was cool
and all and one last one that the
Slenderman music no that's yeah that's
the slider man music why is there the
Slenderman music I'm in a hunt for a
secret key I bet have a I have a feeling
I got a fever and the only prescription
there's more secret keys I do a terrible
Christopher Walken I do a terrible it's
locked with a simple mechanism well that
was easy
who's easy all right so what do we got
here
ah confessional booth which side do I go
in which side do I go in oh hello
confessions who keeps texting me what am
I doing here
Hey hi thank you she dick all right now
that thing is on fire and the sledding
and music has reached a fever pitch why
is this on fire oh the power of ground
Cabal you okay I'll run that way oh no I
will not run that way
[Music]
come on where you going buddy okay he's
going that way I'm gonna stay back here
what is he doing is he going to the
confessional I bet he's going to the
confessional oh I bet I was supposed to
run that way wasn't I come at me bro
come at me bro I'm going this way you go
eff off
thank you I'm in the confession booth
I'm not so sure I was supposed to come
in here where am I supposed to go
come confess your sins a monster
well that wasn't fair holy items can
deter the father well okay the power of
the NFL compels you
I'm just gonna start piling up up here
come on Kim
that is really freaky by the by hey
jumbo ski you're gonna you're gonna suck
these crosses down [ __ ] I'm the Bible
some ha ha ha ha ha it's working somehow
don't know how but it seems to have an
effect on him head risky risky ok hey
it's working what is he doing
I'm not entirely sure it appears to be
working
suck it down [ __ ] he's doing something
I think he's on a pre-scripted bath it's
not sure what in the door Oh Hallie help
what am I supposed to do wait a minute
what am I doing here what am i what am i
one of my one of my eye oh you [ __ ]
dude that's right back off what what am
i doing what am I do
what am I do do I need to hit him a lift
like every single thing in here no you
didn't hear [ __ ] buddy I missed oh Jesus
stop getting so close before you start
running away I dropped some Bibles over
here lay them out in his path well what
am I supposed to do oh there can't be
many more pesky
Habakkuk wait wonder more I dropped some
didn't I
oh god I'm all out oh no oh oh
seriously what am I supposed to do she's
just walking a loop and if so why I
gotta get him in here then I gotta lock
him in that's right ah I gotta lock him
in here come on come on back up I closed
lock closed yes I can you know you won't
I win you lose
right
I'm not going very fast
did our one did I did i won
[Music]
[Laughter]
we
[Music]
aha well this looks almost nice except
for that statute oh not this place again
no please not the kitchen I hate of the
kitchen
[Music]
oh the kitchen got better thank you for
taking the pig away
[Music]
and now that thing is filled with pigs
and blood that's not much better
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay
oh I thought that was the end stop the
end chapter three rain I still can't
move very well oh oh oh
haha secret key number three
I'm not done yet apparently so there's
some more to go through well I don't
know how much more what
isn't you
it's just I knew it it's just me all
along I'm mirroring about mr. mansion
searching for a selfish endeavor to calm
I knew it I called that I called that I
did I called that okay so we are all at
a time and we'll find out the end of
this in the next part to come so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Applause]
[Music]